We've got a full load of salads,...
...and that's lettuces, radishes, onions, spring onions, and Chinese lettuces.
In this room, it is our operation centre.
The map on the wall is a tracking system that we use on our vehicles.
It shows us where they are, it updates at every ninety seconds...
...and we use it to make sure that we are running to schedule.
If there's any problems, we then inform the customer,...
...and if we have any problems, say with a breakdown or traffic issues,...
...we use it to locate the vehicle and see which ones can help...
...or to direct vehicles around any problems.
That shows our current delivery on time status for our main customers.
The main customer we do from this site is supermarket destination Tesco's,...
...so we show that separately,...
...but we also show a separate set of figures for all the other work that's done...
...within this part of the operation.
So that the guys can focus making sure we achieve at least ninety percent delivery on time.
Which doesn't sound that much but that doesn't take into account...
...any road problems, any breakdowns, any of that comes out of our ten percent.
One little accident causes us a lot of problems.
Basically, from this site here we operate all the temperature-controlled trailers.
We control them.
There is about 440.
We utilise them through our other sites, throughout the country...
...that also work on the same operation.
But any information that is put into any of our traffic management systems feeds onto that board,...
...it shows what vehicle, what trailers are available, which ones are due for service,...
...which ones are released and due for service shortly.